my key to success for you or for anybody
else is make sure you're the first one
in there every day and the last one
believe don't ever take a lunch break or
go to the bathroom you keep work and you
never know when that opportunity is
gonna come along if you want to make
change you've got to do it yourself you
can find something you really enjoy
doing
you should lean into that wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
so love you and I believe Life Ball
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back it lack a belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the top 10 rules
of success from the 2020 presidential
candidates
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work hard with Michael Bloomberg I'm
not smarter than anybody else but I can
outwork you and my key to success for
you or for anybody else's make sure
you're the first one in there every day
and the last one to leave don't ever
take a lunch break or go to the bathroom
you keep work and you never know when
that opportunity is gonna come along and
at Salomon Brothers the managing partner
of the company bill Solomon was the
second person in I was the only other
one in the big trading room so if he had
needed to borrow a match in those days
people smoked cigars and if he wanted to
ask something about a newspaper or a
stock he came over and so we became
buddies I would never have gotten to
talk to the managing partner of a big
company on a first-name basis if it
wasn't for the fact that the tools there
Billy I'm getting coffee would you like
some and I can bring you in a bit and at
the end of the day the number-two guy
John good friend he was the last one to
leave except for me and we'd share a cab
going uptown or take the subway train
going uptown together and you know every
opportunity I ever had it was I think
good laugh a lot of them was because I
was there at the time and that's the one
thing you can control you can continue
can't control your luck but the hardy
work the luckier get you can't control
that you're the smartest guy they'll
always be somebody smarter but if you're
there then you absorb things you put
things together in a ways that if you
didn't have all that experience it's
like skiing I've said reading a book on
skiing doesn't teach you how to ski yeah
you got to go and you got a ski and get
lots of miles under your skis and
incidentally if you don't fall you're
not skiing hard enough and you're not
learning anything so if your career has
Sundowns I got fired didn't turn out so
bad but you know you can start a little
business and maybe it doesn't work and
after a while you got to be smarter to
say hey I tried it don't let you go
getting away I can't keep doing this
I've got to earn a living but you know a
year from now I'm gonna come up with a
better idea and then I'll go back and do
it again
rule number two take action with Amy
Klobuchar when our daughter was born she
was really sick she was in intensive
care and back then the insurance
companies had a rule that you were
kicked out in 24 hours no matter what
was going on and I remember thinking I
bet this wouldn't happen to the wife of
the insurance company CEO it made me
realize you know what if you want to
make change you've got to do it yourself
I went to the legislature as a mom and
got one of the first laws passed in the
country guaranteeing new moms and their
babies a 48-hour hospital stay and what
I most remember about that is people
were saying they were for it but they
were trying to delay the bill from
taking effect so I brought six pregnant
friends to the conference committee so
they outnumbered the lobbyists two to
one and when the legislature said when
should this bill take effect all the
pregnant moms raised their hand they're
like now and that's exactly what
happened they moved up the effective
date it became a long rule number three
do what you love with Andrew yang you
want what I say to young people and this
is gonna sound like that like movie
advice you got that there's a peer and
we're like I don't believe that advice
but it's going to become better advice
over time it's really important to find
something that you enjoy and like
because if you enjoy it then you're more
likely to invest time in it and become
good at it and develop like skills that
are resilient over time so believe it or
not if you're a young person you can
find something you really enjoy doing
you should lean into that and a lot of
that revolves around interpersonal
dynamics and skills because team
building is going to become crucial over
time and in a world where you know
dealing with people is going to become a
massive value-add so that that's one
thing I'd say is and it sounds like 80s
movies advice or something but if you
can find something you'd like doing just
really trying it good at it rule number
four
bet on yourself with Tom Styer you were
a rising star at Goldman when Wall
Street was booming and then in less than
a year you had moved to San Francisco to
start up a small merger arbitrage hedge
fund what gave you the confidence to
make this sudden change so let's be
clear when I moved back out here from
Goldman first of all my wife and I
wanted to live west of the Mississippi
period so I knew that Goldman Sachs was
in New York and therefore I was gonna
have to leave it's also true that I got
in a gigantic fight with the guy I was
working for and therefore I felt like
under no circumstances do I want to
continue to go to work and see that guy
every morning mm-hmm which is not a
great career move but also I felt like
if you're one of the things I love about
investing is you can measure the results
and I felt like if I do a bad job at
Goldman Sachs they're gonna fire me if I
do a bad job on my own I'm also gonna
get fired
but if I do a good job on my own I have
much more upside than I do at Goldman
Sachs and so I didn't think I was taking
more risk because I felt like either way
if you don't do a good job in life it
doesn't work out so I was more than
willing to bet on myself in the sense
that if if you're taking that risk
anyway why not at least give yourself
the upside also if you want to have more
confidence check in my to do our series
they're free the link to join our in the
description below maybe someone in your
family has lost their job and there's
not enough money to go around maybe you
live in a neighborhood where you don't
feel safe or have friends we're
pressuring you to do things you know
aren't right you know some people hate
spiders some people hate snakes
I hate it poverty I couldn't stand it
did you ever throw a Bible at your house
no I didn't do you have a terrible
temper no but I do get angry about
things so I'm not gonna deny that rule
number five inspire others with who Leon
Castro is it inspiring to have like
young people coming up to you and
a few years ago when I was thirty years
old I ran to become the city's youngest
elected mayor ever and I lost but one of
the things I remembered about the
campaign was that during the campaign a
lot of parents would come up to me and
they wanted to introduce their daughter
or their son so that they could point
and say that you can do that because
when I was walking these halls I never
imagined that I would be the one that
people would be coming up to and saying
and you know okay take a picture with
you or you know I hope I could do what
you did rule number six stand up for
what you believe with Bernie Sanders
what else do you have for young people
who have a passion for politics embers
potentially want to pursue careers in
politics and political and public
service our business mining bus okay I
don't like the word passion for politics
what I prefer is and you've got about
the autonomous one passion for justice
okay
I have talked to a lot of people you
know your sanity you thoughtful of you
and kids come up to the mix I want to be
a governor I want to be President I want
to be a sentiment and that doesn't
interest me at all well interest me is
when somebody tells me they're concerned
about the health care crisis in America
when they concerned about poverty how
can they do something about there's a
lot of ways to do it
one of the ways is running for office
not the only way we're raising the
minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour
not because of political decisions it
started with grassroots activism
actually then politics get there so I
would say to answer your question it's
not the one go into your gut go into
your gut not necessarily easy what do
you believe what do you really believe
think about it it's not something you
love right away what are your passions
do you have the courage to stand up the
people who want to reject you or push it
around okay and if you have those
qualities jump in I mean politics in
getting involved in spending up to me an
extraordinary ride when I was mayor of
early you know what we did we literally
broke down the door of City Hall with
little bubbles literally did we took on
an entire establishment which by the way
the heads of the question was a
Democratic Party and we took them pushes
on the side
we brought hundreds and hundreds of
people in the political process we
started programs for young people for
all people for women in the environment
for the Arts it was an extraordinary
experience with just so much excitement
so much energy all right it's a lot of
fun but the main thing you have to do
don't do it if you're just thinking
about in your career if all I'm saying
think about is a mechanism one way that
you can bring change to this world and
if that's what you want go for it and
have the guts to stand up and fight for
what you believe rule number seven get
rid of credit card debt with Elizabeth
Warren what's an unexpected step we can
take help prepare ourselves for a
financial emergency get rid of the most
dangerous thing in your wallet and that
is your credit card
kind of carny okay it's carrying credit
card debt I'm serious about this I
really am credit card debt is incredibly
dangerous to carry and and the way to
think about this is if you're carrying a
balance from month to month to month it
should be like a warning light goes off
you know bells are ringing every time
you pull that credit card out again
because it means not only are you not
making your monthly expenses you're
spending more you've got it means you're
paying more because you're paying
interest on all that and if something
goes wrong you're already in a little
bit of trouble and a little bit of
trouble can turn into a lot of trouble
in a hurry so I'm really down on credit
card debt rule number eight be a leader
with Pete Budaj
I had experiences with bullying when I
was growing up and everybody who's
different can be bullied and that the
secret is everybody is different in some
way so the first thing you got to know
is you have nothing to be ashamed of and
the second part this is a much harder
part to remember is that the the person
who's bullying you probably has
something a little a little broken in
them it's part of why they're trying to
get your attention that they they want
to get a response out of you they want
to kind of control a situation because
something else in their life isn't going
well and they don't feel they have
control in a bigger way it sounds
familiar yeah I think it really matters
that we have a president who doesn't
show that kind of behavior it's one of
the reasons I'm running for president
[Applause]
so the hard part if you really want to
just take all the air out of that
bullying is turn to a bully and ask if
they're okay and they won't know what to
do with you you have control over
whether that bully makes you into a
worse version of yourself or a better
version of yourself best thing you can
do to show them and push them away is to
not let them have that power over you
when you're being bullied somebody else
is watching and they don't know what to
do
maybe they'll laugh along with the bully
because they're nervous and they're
afraid to and so when you show that it
doesn't get to you when you show that
you got the bigger heart there are
people who you won't even realize are
gonna follow your lead and you ought to
think of yourself as a leader especially
in that moment when somebody's trying to
break you down and you could make a
whole bunch of people's lives better as
you go rule number nine take
responsibility with Cory Booker so if
you're using your social media only for
trivialities then you're not being an
advocate for justice and so if you say
I'm gonna be consistent once a week
posting about this issue I'm gonna get
folk woke and and hopefully get some
action done I just forget Millennials
every anybody who is young yeah every
generation of the youth are usually at
the center of great justice movements
all around the planet Earth and so you
decide what am I gonna do am I gonna be
a spectator or am I gonna be a
participant am I gonna be sitting back
watching the world or I'm gonna be one
of those people finding ways every day
to challenge the world because we have
one choice to make every day of our
lives in fact every hour of our lives we
accept things as they are or we take
some responsibility for changing and
rule number ten the last one before very
special bonus clip is follow your heart
with Joe Biden dear Joe
you're only 12 your stutter is
debilitating it embarrasses you and the
bullies are vicious listen to mom when
she says bravery resides in every art
and yours is fierce and clear listen to
dad when he says Joey when you get
knocked down get up get up because if
you listened you'll summon the bravery
to overcome the stutter and you'll learn
to stand up to bullies
you'll learn from dad who moved the
family to look for work that a job is
about a lot more than a paycheck it's
about your dignity it's about respect
hi are you know why it's my name and
that's why you'll follow your heart and
serve your community your state in your
country and intolerance for the abuse of
power will drive you to stand up for
civil rights and that we have favorites
in South Africa the favorites in South
Africa are the people who are being
repressed
because you listened you'll live a life
fully consistent with what you are
taught by mom and dad and your faith
that you should say what you mean and
mean what you say
leading by the power for example will
define you and one day you'll find
yourself forging the relationship with
the Jesuit Pope embodies that universal
truth now I have a special bonus tip
with Donald Trump on how to create your
own luck but before that I'm curious
what do you think do you like this video
it's a new style that we're playing with
they try to shine some light on the
election and maybe learn some things
from the candidates in a positive way
without them just slamming each other
let me know what you think put it down
in the comments below
and if you're still here watch this
video I want to celebrate you thank you
so much give me a hashtag believe in the
comments as well what would be one word
of advice you would have for an upcoming
businessman knowledge knowledge but if
it's one word one word it's very hard
for that but the word is knowledge but
you get knowledge through experience one
of the things people talk about is luck
and I do believe that people are lucky
and some people are luckier than others
I do believe that but there's also an
expression the harder you work the
luckier you get and I can tell you ten
instances where I didn't quit one it was
1990 the world was coming down the debt
markets would everybody all of my
friends and enemies were going bankrupt
I never did and the but try I mean the
times were actually just terrible and
even today you look at times and you see
what happens and you have to learn but
the word luck is very interesting but if
I didn't work really hard I probably
would not almost definitely would not be
here today and unless you had me up as a
man who at one point was successful but
let's see what a loser looks like so you
have to work hard because it is true you
can develop luck through hard work
if you want to see john f kennedy's top
10 or also success check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and i'll
see you there
and what you can do for your country
all we have built all we have work for
would be destroyed in the first 24 hours